hi thank you for so much for joining us
this afternoon
we are really excited to celebrate the
second season of foundering
our next episode drops tomorrow
foundering is our serialized podcast
from bloomberg technology
where each season we go deep into one
controversy within the tech industry
this season is about tick-tock my name
is sean wenn
i'm the executive producer of the show
i'd like to do
to introduce shelley banjo shelly is the
host of the season
she's been reporting on tick tock for
over four years now
hi shelley how are you good
up next is kurt wagner kurt is the
social media reporter at bloomberg he's
been covering social media now for
almost
eight years and joined bloomberg two
years ago he works in our san francisco
office hey kurt
hey sean up next is marjorie roberts
margie worked at musically the app that
eventually became
folded into tick tock in san francisco
and then la
from 2016 to the fall of 2017 sheila
musically's partnerships with some of
the music labels
and worked with influencers and musical
artists to get onto the app
now she lives in atlanta and she runs
her own startup
focused on beauty and personal care
product reviews hey marjay thanks for
coming on the show
hi everybody thanks for having me hi
um next is john boyd bolton who helped
start a company called flipagram
that was acquired by tick tock's parent
company bite dance in 2017.
john stayed on that by dance for a few
years he helped
bite dance acquire musically and sign
record deals with the world's largest
record labels
and he's still a shareholder at bite
dance john now lives in nashville and is
the co-founder of super hi-fi
an ai platform that powers next
generation listening experiences
for music and audio platforms hey john
hello good to be here so this is going
to be
a one hour event tonight we're going to
listen to a few clips from the show
and then shelly kerr margie john and i
will have a short conversation
and you can ask us questions too please
tweet your questions
to at podcasts at business
or put them in the chat with uh youtube
um but first we're gonna
play a clip from the show shelly will
you help set this up
yeah so this clip um is a peek inside
the early days of musically
and you'll hear marjay talk a little bit
about her time there in the clip
okay cool
oh it definitely did not feel like an
american
company we were in constant everyday
contact with the chinese team
we very much took a lot of our cues from
the chinese team especially since our
founders were based
there for the majority of the time
musically opened its first u.s outpost
in a scrappy we work in san francisco
here's margie we worked in a rework room
it was one
room yes so we crammed in as much as we
can
that was very much like harry potter in
a closet
there was a lot of urgency and
excitement here's jaja
who was so impressed by musically's rise
she decided to go work for them
you know we were ready to kick it off
our second summer really
it's an important time because this one
kids are out of school and they're bored
at home
you know it was a great opportunity for
us to take the groove to the next level
and that's when the venture capitalists
rushed in
by 2016 musically had raised over 150
million dollars
from some of silicon valley's biggest vc
firms it surpassed over 100 million
downloads
and the app was a huge sensation among
teenagers
even if it was virtually unknown to
adults here's marche again
muesli was very underground but i
discovered that
gen z knew all about it but no one else
did
so um i actually reached out to my niece
she's a preteen at the time
i was like do you know what this app is
called musically
and this was the moment of truth she
literally almost had a heart attack
she's like
oh my god it's the biggest it's the
coolest app ever i
love it i'm obsessed with it i'm like
what is going on
musically allowed you to shoot a video
and then with a touch of a button
add effects and a soundtrack within
seconds you have this striking
finished product how to be a british
stereotype drink lots of tea
units one challenge
and gen z took to it you go do that
because i love you so much
the short form video format is very
perfect for
uh younger folks because it requires a
very little attention span
quite honestly and i think ultimately
which is very easy to get using
you know it didn't require you to create
an original song or create
you know an original joke you could get
started on the platform very easily by
using
um an existing clip or an existing song
cause i know
their team users got the hang of it
quickly and some of them were so good at
making these entertaining
short videos they were getting famous on
the app uh thanks to all you guys on
musically for supporting me and i hope
you guys like my ep
we would have some of our users come in
and meet the team and they were so
excited to meet
us because they thought that you know
well we make them famous sometimes
so it was pretty great just to be there
like on the ground there
and by famous i mean just a massive
number of eyeballs were on these teen
influencers
even though musically hadn't hit the
mainstream yet they were even beating
out beyonce on instagram
beyonce on instagram posted this picture
of herself
announcing her pregnancy i think um and
it had
a million views or likes in
24 hours the unique difference
with musically is that our everyday
influencers who were not
traditional celebrities were getting
three million
likes in an hour
and we're back um i love that clip
margie i love that part about beyonce it
just
so crystallizes the beginning of
of this really special thing that was
about to happen help us um
paint the picture you know musically was
the app that eventually folded into tick
tock how similar
how similar was it um how similar were
the two apps musically and tick tock
um they're pretty they're very similar
um
you know tick tock has all of the key
components that um
musically had and they almost kind of um
you know uh revolutionized it into what
it
is today um a lot of just different uh
color changes and color schemes from our
pink to
you know the black and white of what tik
tok to say but music essentially
is um tick tock and i think you know
obviously tick tock has
um grown into um you know incorporating
even
even more um uh technology
that allows them to really be able to
tune in to
who their users are and how to keep them
engaged so um it's very very similar
it's almost
um identical in a lot of ways and of
course the mastermind behind
uh musically is one of the founders um
alex jew
tell us a little bit about him do you
did you feel like his originally
original vision of musically kind of
lasted
um through today and is being realized
now
i think in a lot of ways he really was
he was really in tune with
um trying to understand who his
users were um and i think it does
for the most part hold true to what it
is today um it's really about
creating um a space for
for everyday everyday people to express
themselves creatively
um and i think that still rings true um
now i think
um in the past it was very much
more hyper focused on music hence the
name musically um and so
over time um there was definitely
a goal to um diversify the content
making sure that
all type of content was um able to be
um readily accessible and so i think
that's the biggest part is
there's so much more content beyond the
lip syncing that was really the
the main um the key content early on
when it was uh musically based and kurt
i want to
go over to you because we were
reminiscing about um you know writing
about musically
in its early days and you know you've
been covering social media for almost a
decade now
what at the time do you remember like
what stood out
for you at musically why was this
something that you're like oh i should
probably
pay attention to this yeah i mean
musically and then tick tock popped up
on my radar
at different parts over the last four or
five years you know i think
musically at first started catching the
attention of other people in the
industry who were like
to margie's point we're noticing these
incredible
um engagement metrics and they were like
oh my gosh look at this video it has
3 million likes or whatever it may be
right but at the time
you know musically felt like it was very
young
in terms of the audience like it was it
wasn't just teenagers it was like young
teenagers and so as a result
a lot of people kind of dismissed it
certainly i did i was kind of like oh
it's this popular thing but like
it's it's too young right it's not it's
not gonna catch on
and then when bite dance bought
musically for 800 million dollars
um that was like oh my gosh okay you
don't spend 800 million dollars on
on something unless there's some real
potential there and so i think i started
paying closer attention and by
i was trying to think about this shelly
like early 2019 i think is when i
started seeing tick-tock videos
on my instagram feed and that's when i
was like
okay this is an app that i have i've
been aware of but i've kind of been
neglecting
for too long and about early to mid 2019
i was like
if this is half of my instagram feed now
i need to start paying closer attention
to this app
and and i'd say about that point is when
i really um you know for me
it started to register as a force that i
should be paying attention to
yeah that reminds me because that must
have been right around the time when
they started taking out all those ads
john uh you remember these ads that they
would put with the install button
um and across all of social social media
why were those so important
well i think once uh bike dance
took control musically and and really
turned it into tick tock the
the they kind of got a use case that was
working really well
and actually had a an organic
acquisition play to it like if you see
it a tick tock on instagram
um you know people like oh wow tick tock
i'll go download that app
but what bike dance did was invest just
massive amounts
of on acquisition and you know there's
articles all over the place you'll see
where
you know twitter and facebook and
snapchat are seeing their largest
advertisers pythons
just you know extremely aggressive paid
acquisition campaigns and
and the they work because when people
click on that and download the app
they're instantly addicted there's a lot
of apps that do paid acquisition where
they get you in there
but they don't hold you like like tick
tock holds you
and so when you pour that kind of money
into paid acquisition and then have the
kind of engagement that comes from it
well you have what you have now which is
an extremely valuable company
it's only growing and a lot of people
talk about musically but
uh another app that they acquired was
flipagram which is the company that you
helped found
um tell us what that was like
and you know had you heard of bite dance
before what did you think about when
they acquired your company
well flipagram went viral in in early
2014
this was well before musically well
before bike dance was known anywhere
uh beyond uh in fact i don't even know
if they were known in china then but
flippagram stumbled on something which
was allowing people to make
short videos with pictures and adding
popular music clips
and then they would share that with
their friends on instagram and so this
thing just went wildly
uh know viral in 2014 it was the top
downloaded app in the world
uh for for the first half of 2014. um
that that sparked something and and i
i i know that even you know musically
saw that
in 2014 and saw what happened there and
musically evolved
quite a bit on the flipagram use case
but
that um you know when all that was going
on we saw musically start to really
become popular really in 2015 is when
there was like this big challenge that
went viral and we saw that
we saw him climb the app store charts
and we were like man they're doing
something
better than what we're doing and uh
when all that was going on though um
when we found out
the founder was in china we were like
what we're like
it just didn't make sense i mean nothing
like this comes out of china
and so um we we were we talked to out we
reached out to alex the moment uh they
popped in the app store and we were like
what are you guys doing
do you want to work together we were
like can we buy this thing somehow like
we were you know just
scrambling to to figure out what what
they were doing
uh and and to figure out is there even a
way to collaborate but
they they smoked us in convenience
they didn't need us we needed them how
do you think they had such a hold on
american culture like they
it was almost like alex knew what
american teens
wanted you know more than anyone else
well i met with one not alex one of the
other founders in beijing after
we acquired them at bite dance and um
he told me a story about a high school
in texas that
that they they had been trying musically
in other parts of the world they
started in asia which is the natural you
know starting your own backyard right
it wasn't working and um he said
something happened
they they were really focused on uh
this high school in texas he told me
they were telling him
hey if you do this this is interesting
and something happened there
and you know i don't know all the
details of it but you know they
they a lot of iteration a lot of testing
and a hyper focus
on the user and understanding what they
want
and and just hitting it out of the park
um
is is sort of what we saw there
yeah that actually brings up an
interesting memory i have
um john i uh with with
one of the other uh founders of
musically we also went to
we did a lot of focus groups um even
um back then 2016 time frame uh we would
we would actually we did a
actually arranged a school focus group
with
um some high schoolers to get some fee
and we actually brought in our
co-founder of musical and he actually
went to a local
la california high school to for us to
get feedback from
some of the local kids in um in that
area
and it just speaks to just how
boots on the ground we were about
learning about what
what kids wanted what um our our users
wanted to see
and what we were building for them to to
make it to make it
what it is today for sure
this is a great segue into our second
clip uh
this is a look inside tick tock's parent
company
by dance's beijing office okay
emerged as a different sort of chinese
employer
china has a reputation for low wages and
sprawling factories
but yamin was paying some of the highest
salaries in the market
here's humming with my colleague peter
what is the top of the market
in terms of ai engineers now what kind
of salary is salary for the unlimited
talent
i'm sure they'd love to hear that
[Music]
unlimited salary for unlimited talent
sounds like a platitude but it's not let
me underscore how unusual this
is at bite dance there was no ceiling
for how much top employees could earn
some engineers were making one million
dollars a year
and ymin was often paying 50 percent
more than his competitors
throwing money at a problem became
something yming would do again
and again as his company grew bigger he
saw that paying top dollar to hire
employees
acquire other startups and buy
advertising could serve as a kind of
shortcut to success
that he could turbocharge his growth by
just paying for it
and as fast as he was spending money
even more money kept flowing in
from venture capital backers many of
whom were american
yiming raised almost eight billion
dollars in vc money
in 2018 white dance surpassed uber and
became the world's most valuable startup
it's even overtaken companies like
starbucks and goldman sachs
the buckets of cash from big investors
like softbank and sequoia
gave bite dance a mandate and the means
to start expanding around the world
part of the purpose of that raise was
for bike dents to essentially go global
to go beyond
the borders of china and take their
unique technology
and really with our secret sauce is this
ai that can effectively learn a user
user's preference and serve them content
with a precision that you know i've not
seen anyone else really do
that's john again who worked at
flipagram the slideshow app by dance
acquired in 2016.
he said this would be a big deal no
chinese consumer app had ever hit it big
in the us
john stayed on staff at bike dance for a
couple of years helping the company buy
more american startups and sign music
deals with u.s record labels
he says the first time he walked into by
dance's beijing headquarters
he was floored by just how many people
were lining up to get in
i think it when i joined it was a few
thousand employees and when i left it
was like
thirty thousand or something crazy but i
remember the first day
uh in beijing at headquarters i
was in the lobby and there was i don't
know like a hundred people
i met up with uh the woman i'd worked
for there and i said what's what is that
she's like oh those are new hires
and i was like oh my god that's crazy
and then what i realized
that happened every day every day there
was this huge
you know group of new employees
we'll be right back
i love that clip of john i love the
picture that you paint
um of being inside of bike dance and
tell us more what that felt like you
know take us back to that
waiting room and tell us what that felt
like to see that kind of growth
it was extraordinary i i've i've never
i've been at big companies i interned at
18t in college
i've seen big companies but i i have not
seen anything like that
and that office
uh that i went to i
had a hotel down the road and i'd walk
there and it's this big building
and you go in and you have this giant
crowd of
of people in the lobby
that are all there for orientation
and and i really and i would go there
every day and every day there was a
different group there
and it was just a stunning thing and i'm
like where are they going what are these
people doing
i don't really understand how you hire
that fast
um and a lot of it was i think modern
content moderation so it's not like they
were
all like these you know executives or
something but
the the hiring was extraordinary but the
the culture and uh there was this just
excitement there was something going on
there
i don't even really know early on what
was going on there yet but i realized
something big is happening here
because of what was going on with tick
tock because of this
insane volume of hiring
and you know i'd walk around the office
and just a lot of excitement
and and people sleeping because they
work constantly
um but you know you go to the cafeteria
this huge cafeteria where the food's
free uh you know very much like a google
type thing they want to be they aspire
to be like i think an american tech
company in a lot of ways there's these
american quotes all over i would see
ray dalio was on this loop video
for the whole month um but
you know that is cafeteria with i don't
know maybe hundreds of people
at lunch time just in this section that
i was in so
a massive thing that was going on and
still obviously is going on there
and um one thing that you worked on in
particular was
about music and and margie i want to
bring you in here
also but um let's start with john why
was music so important
to the genesis of this and also the
staying power
well music is why flipagram hit it
uh big and it's why musically hit it big
music
is you know that's sort of peak pop
culture
music is used uh you know it's the
ultimate filter
see all you know it's an audio filter
but it's the ultimate filter when
you take a video and you talking
dancing whatever it is without music
and then you add the music you've got
two fundamentally different things
and so the music is magic and and
musically
you know at the time in 16 17 and
18 when it required it was still
fundamental to
the to the use case um i don't think it
is as much anymore i mean my tick tock
feed now is mostly comedians who are
incredible but there's no music
but back then um and i would say even
still now
um the music allows you to express
yourself and entertain people and and do
these almost
memes um in ways that if you didn't have
it
you're dead in the water you just
wouldn't work if you took the music
you took the music out of tic toc now i
think they would have a
major problem and so it's just
fundamental to the
the core object that is a tick tock
video
and margie tell us about what it was
like you know trying to get these
musicians
um early on to sign on to the app and
you know teach them
about what what this is and how to use
it for sure yeah
just to piggyback off of what john was
saying like you know music
is the language of the world and it's so
relatable and anyone can
really engage with it um and so i think
that's what really
made the app um so exciting to
kind of engage with but uh you know
early on
um it was it was very it was a very
interesting experience
trying to get artists on because as uh
kurt was saying
um at the beginning it felt like it was
a very young app and so a lot of artists
weren't sure if they felt comfortable
with engaging because they're like oh
there's a lot of young
young teenagers on here um and so
really you know sharing the numbers and
sharing the engagement numbers and
and comparing them similar to like a
beyonce video versus
you know baby arielle or jacob sartorius
who were very popular
at the time on the app comparing
their ability to be able to um
amplify a song just by lip syncing it or
um or dancing to it in in one video
um had the potential to put to possibly
uh impact billboard billboard charts
which it
which we found um in some respects had
direct correlations
um and so i think when they saw the
numbers and they understood like just
how impactful
um being early on to do an app um that
was growing
um and could grow with you um when they
saw that i think that's what
what got them um excited about it i
think um
uh you know one example i remember is
uh nicki minaj um
she learned about it a lot from um jason
darillo who was one of our first
artists that was really vocal on it
yeah he he was the original he was our
our biggest artist even at the beginning
and um
they had a song together and when she
saw that
that song was was charting and doing so
well because of
uh all of the musically engagement on it
um we ended up having i ended up having
a meeting with her manager
about um us doing a a full campaign with
her
and um bringing the three queens of
musically to meet her
at her um at her music video to create
musically together with her new song
and that once again really amplified
millions and millions of views and and
not just views i think that's the unique
thing about musically
um it was the creation of videos using
the music
that's a true form of engagement that is
unlike any anywhere else
you can get a view on a bit on a video
but for someone to have
created a scenario or or a video around
your song
is a true form of engagement that wasn't
found anywhere else and that was really
something that we saw
um take off really well so you taught
nicki minaj how to make a ticket
we did i did along with our
along with some of our other users that
we invited to her
her video shoot so very cool times um
being able to
engage with a lot of the artists there
that's awesome i love what you're saying
about um
that the music doesn't need a language
because
i think that that um helped tic toc grow
so wildly globally because you could do
these dances and you could do
all these different things because you
didn't need to be um
you need to need to know the language
the same way you do on like a twitter or
facebook totally for sure
yeah if i could add the the labels and
getting artists on
getting the labels comfortable with with
flipagram with musically with tiktok
the there was some reluctance because
it's user-generated content
and so artists and writers have their
contracts with the labels and publishers
and they say look
you know you got to be careful what you
do with my music and so the labels and
publishers
say you know some of the videos that
come out of these services
aren't that great and and some of them
might be offensive
and so there was some real reluctance
and concern about just
pairing their music with ugc videos but
as margie explained the benefits far far
and we now know far out you know
away the the the risks that come with it
but the other thing
rj said the that um it's like mini
advertisements right i make a tick tock
video
with with a nicki minaj song
now all my followers and my friends who
may not know nicki minaj or
you know just don't listen to her music
but now all of a sudden they're like wow
this song's great who is that oh it's
nicki minaj and that was one of the
key selling points with the industry
early on is that
you know you're talking about hundreds
of millions of mini
ads with your music flying across social
media
every month you're saying you don't want
that and they're like well yeah you're
probably right that's
that's probably a good thing and it's
like yeah it's a good thing let's do
this
as a as a user of tick tock i can just
say that that works tremendously well i
discover
i am not very uh up to speed on new
music
but i often will first hear songs
through a tick-tock video um that i
probably wouldn't have discovered
otherwise so it's it still works even if
you're not
15 15 years old you're still discovering
music that way
yeah but i realize you always have to be
careful because
i we realized we ended up only knowing
15 to 30 seconds of the songs because
that's the one that would loop over and
over again so we thought that was always
funny we were like we actually don't
know this whole song
but everyone only knows the chorus
anyway right right
right so as tiktok was changing
the music industry and the social media
industry
everything seemed like it was on the up
and up but pretty soon
anti-tick tock sentiment in the u.s
started getting in the way of the app's
growth so we're gonna play another clip
and uh this is again from the foundering
podcast which you can download for free
from apple or spotify
um one very famous person
is trying to stoke anti-tick tock
sentiment in washington
here we go
sentiment was building and there was one
person
in particular who was cheering
facebook's
mark zuckerberg for years zuckerberg saw
tiktok grow
becoming a major competitor drawing
people away from facebook and instagram
so zuckerberg decides to issue his own
warning to washington
he had been called up to congress to
defend accusations that facebook had
gotten too big
instead he uses this chance to deflect
attention to china
here's senator dan sullivan from alaska
questioning zuckerberg
mr zuckerberg quite a story right dorm
room through the global behemoth that
you guys are
only in america would you agree with
that
senator mostly you couldn't do this in
china right or
what you did ten years well senator
there are there are some very strong
chinese internet companies
right but you're supposed to answer yes
to this question
okay come on this is trying to help you
right i mean give me a break
the answer is yes okay so thank you um
the senators are all laughing but
zuckerberg is looking ahead
barely blinking with a super straight
face
because zuckerberg came before congress
with very specific talking points
that chinese internet companies like tik
tok needed to be stopped
he says the issue is bigger than
facebook and that the rise of china's
tech companies were a huge threat to
america
is face one of the key issues here is is
facebook
too powerful are you too powerful and
do you think you're too powerful well
senator i think most of the time when
people talk about our scale
they're referencing that we have two
billion people in our community
and i think one of the big questions
that we need to think through here
is the vast majority of those two
billion people are outside of the u.s
and i think that that's something that
to your point that americans should be
proud of
okay and when i brought up the chinese
internet companies i think that that's a
real
uh a real strategic and competitive
threat that
in in american technology let me give
you another point here real quick
i wanna i don't wanna interrupt but this
was a huge 180 for zuckerberg
he spent years trying to get into the
good graces of the chinese government
because facebook was banned in china he
learned mandarin
and bragged about speaking to china's
president xi jinping
he was so confident about winning china
over
but none of it worked and zuckerberg
eventually gave up
he shifted gears and china became the
enemy
in a later speech at georgetown
university zuckerberg named tiktok
directly
while our services like whatsapp are
used by protesters and activists
due to strong encryption and privacy
protections on tick tock the chinese app
growing quickly around the world
mentions of these same protests are
censored even here in the u.s
[Music]
is that the internet that we want we'll
be right back
[Music]
again just a reminder to folks watching
you're listening to live q a of
foundering the tick tock story and if
you have any questions about
the rise of tick tock or where we are
now with tick tock please send them
on on twitter um or on youtube and um
we are happy to take audience questions
anytime
um i want to go over to you kurt uh to
reflect a little bit about the clip we
just heard and
the reason why we talk about zuckerberg
and facebook in this process
in this podcast is because um it was the
first app in a while to really come and
shake mark zuckerberg up at his core you
know
tell us a little bit about why mark
zuckerberg is
in front of congress talking about china
well mark zuckerberg understands
the power of china probably as as well
as any
tech executive in part because to your
point shelley he's been trying to get
into china with his own products for
over a decade without any success um
and he's gone to great lengths to try
and get there i mean when you think
about what facebook's goal is it's
connecting the world right how do you do
that when the most populous country
in the world does not have access to
your products so
he has always thought of china as this
you know crown jewel if you will of like
getting
his mission out there and i think at a
certain point when he realized okay
this isn't gonna happen for me suddenly
he
also appreciated the fact that well the
reason it was so valuable to me is that
it's valuable to other people too and
that china is a market that is now a
threat to me right if i can't operate
there
that means that other people that are
suddenly operating in the world's most
populous country
are a threat to facebook and i think you
know a big a big thing
that doesn't necessarily get said quite
as as bluntly but is relevant here
is that they see um you know the
internet rules in china as being unfair
right they they don't think that the
rest of the world gets to play by the
same rules and as a result
they're worried that if tick tock fight
dance
um if other chinese companies become the
the most popular
those kind of rules of the internet will
extend to india right which is a massive
country where facebook is popular
they'll extend to other parts of asia
where facebook is trying to have a
foothold and so
i think not only is he afraid that he
he's missed out on china i think that's
an obvious one
but i think he's now worried that the
rise of these chinese companies are
going to
edge him or or shoulder him out of some
of the other markets facebook really
cares about
i think india being probably number one
on their list
and facebook even tried to buy tick tock
at one point right
that's right i mean facebook tries to
buy almost everything that poses a
any kind of competitive threat to them
um but tick tock
was no exception um you know now in the
most recent round of discussions
facebook wasn't really a serious player
because they're dealing with a lot of
anti-trust uh issues and and regulatory
issues and of course you have the ceo of
facebook coming over and saying
hey china's a real threat be wary of
tick-tock you can't necessarily then go
buy tick-tock that that isn't a great
look for him but
this was a many years ago when um you
know
facebook was in that position and and
they did give it a look and they decided
to pass and
i'm sure that you know in hindsight uh
that was probably a decision he would
like to have back
so we have a um a question from the
audience i hope that i pronounced this
correctly
um uh youtube viewer ozone and um
osun says how can you state that
tick-tock is changing social media
when big creators are trying to move and
diversify
their following to other social media
platforms and i think
you know what he's referencing in is
after the
trump ban earlier this summer or last
summer
uh a lot of tick tock uh users
decided oh shoot like if this goes away
i gotta i have to
diversify to build on youtube i have to
build on instagram and reels and
snapchat
um what do you make of that curt do you
think that
um tick-tockers are going to continue to
stay loyal or do you think that
um you know they are going to try to
diversify and and move to other
platforms
i i think uh they are going to diversify
and i think that what we've seen
historically is that if you're a creator
you go
first where you can get the largest
audience and then second where you can
make money
from that audience and that's why
youtube has been really successful for a
lot of places
and that's why you're seeing companies
like facebook and twitter in particular
right now try to scramble to roll out
subscriptions or tipping or
you know whatever you want to call it
because they realize
we offer the audience part but we don't
really offer the the monetization part
and so where i think it's safe
and fair to say that tick tock is
revolutionizing the social media
industry is that when you have a new
player come along that's suddenly
drawing so much attention
it forces the other companies to up
their game right now suddenly
facebook might not be the most instagram
might not be the most popular place
if you want to promote your your music
video so now instagram says
okay shoot well now we have to give them
a way to make money from it because
otherwise
tick tock's just as valuable and and
then you know twitter sees that and they
have to do something even better right
so it's kind of this
keeping up with the jones's idea where
when there's a new entrant that
does something really well it forces
everyone else to kind of
build their own feature set or their own
um you know monetization to try and keep
up and that's where i think
tick tock has probably had the most
influence on the broader industry
and what do you think margie on that
topic
yeah i um i would agree i think that um
there's um it's just really important to
diversify
you uh your platforms um especially
um there's definitely new ones popping
up and there's also more niche
platforms popping up that allows you to
be able to
really hone in into whatever vertical of
content you create such as beauty what
i'm working on or any
um other type of um of a vertical like
comedy and so i think it's
really important to make sure um
you are not counting all your eggs in
one basket
and um diversifying across the board and
uh really keeping on and touched on the
trends
and figuring out what's um always going
to be the next maybe big thing on the
horizon and being in tune with that as
well
while still being able to maintain what
you're what you're doing if i could have
add in here um i i don't think the
band did a thing to tick-tock if you
look at the q1
uh download report tick-tock was number
one
they beat facebook they beat youtube so
there was no slowdown from that there
was concern
and people may have done it but the
thing about tiktok is that
that is a specific type of use case it
is about entertainment
and instagram is not about that twitter
is not about that
youtube is but it's long form it's a
long form platform and
you're competing with so many more
people on there so i
i i don't i agree with you what you guys
are saying but i don't think any
momentum was law i don't think people
were like well
i thought they were going to get banned
so i now i'm done with tick i don't
think that happened
um and again i base it purely on their
download uh data from
from q1 um it shows that they're just
crushing it right now so
this there was probably even more
excitement around it
there was probably even more excitement
around it because
so i think more and more people heard
about it
they were in the news for months and i
think a bunch of people
i know people in my circle were like
what's tick tock i'm like oh
welcome to my world right you know they
didn't know anything about it and now
they
and after all the the the drama they did
know about it
right i think like reflect on that drama
for a minute kurt can you tell us
how crazy was this almost sale process
that never happened but still could
maybe happen
you know bring it break it down for us
real quick it was incredibly crazy as
you know
shelly shelly and i ended up talking a
lot uh
over a couple months stretch at the end
of last year beginning this year
i mean i think the thing there were
there were a bunch of things that just
don't normally happen right and and you
could go all the way to the basic like
m a talks don't normally happen publicly
right you find out that
uh flipagram or musically was acquired
after the deal is
is all finalized and everyone's ready to
announce it you don't see the sausage
getting made
and so we were seeing that now you also
don't see
the president an elected politician
forcing the sale of a private business
right and especially a private business
that is owned by a company in another
country that you're at a you know kind
of a political
geopolitical war with right and so there
were just so many elements to this story
that were
unusual and that were um
things that we had never seen before
that it really
was a bizarre thing to write about and
report about because
every single day felt like there was no
background that you could turn to like
usually you get a story and you're like
okay well i've covered a version of this
before but with this story it was like
well can they do that i don't even know
like we've never seen that before i
guess we need to now go find out so it
was quite it was quite unique i would
say
is that is a kind way of describing it
and so
tick tock is told by president trump you
have 45 days to find a buyer
in the u.s or risk being banned first
they thought they were going to go with
microsoft then they
decided to go with oracle then tick tock
waits out donald trump and donald trump
leaves office
and then you know nothing yet happens
joe biden takes over the presidency and
basically puts a hold on everything you
know um
what do you guys think happens next i
mean let's start with kurt and then i
want to hear from john and margie too
marge
too um i what happens next i don't know
i
it's hard for me to imagine a deal
getting done at this point because
even if um you know in six
months it first of all just doesn't feel
like a priority for the biden
administration which
which is fine but you know as a result
not a lot is happening behind the scenes
i don't believe
and let's pretend six months from now
they pick up this baton and they say
hey you know what we want to do that
well a whole year has gone by right all
of a sudden oracle's business
is in a different place tick tock's
business is in a different place
uh the user base is probably 100 200
million more users than it was
a year ago so they have to kind of start
everything
i would think almost start from scratch
and so
i just don't i i'm not optimistic that
anything gets done
at this stage um it certainly could
but you know we've now been talking
about this for almost a full
year and it doesn't feel like anything
has happened in the last five months
and i'm not getting a sense that that's
going to kick start again
and i'll just uh remind people you're
listening to a live q a about foundering
the tick shock story if you have any
questions
ask us on twitter or on youtube i'll
head over to
john you're still a bike dance investor
um
you know what was it like for you during
this tumultuous period to kind of
have your friends like you mentioned
call you on the phone ask you about it
and
um you know why do you remain invested
in bite dance
well yeah it was all it was pretty
disconcerting all of that
last year i think the thing that
we have yet to see is actual evidence of
some kind of national security threat
that that to me was where i'm like well
what is it what is the problem do you
have a document
is there something that shows the
chinese government's actually involved
and
nothing like that has been shown and so
i think
that kind of was like i think this is
more
politics and other things going on than
an actual
problem which is why it's probably not a
priority for biden
and the byte administration um
but i i i mean i'm i continue to
be involved just because
the tick tock use case is fundamentally
different
than instagram than twitter than youtube
i i think it's superior uh i think it's
a better product
i mean you know anyone who's been on
tick-tock go
you'll see it is it is incredibly
entertaining
and uh and so i i think that and the
fact that it's a chinese company
i just it doesn't i believe very much in
capitalism and competition
and i don't think about you know having
you know zuckerberg having too much
power you know he's going to be out
innovated soon you know just
you look at technology there's always
gets scary oh ibm is too big but you
know look at him now right and so
i i just think uh it doesn't bother me
they're chinese
and after getting to know them which you
know they very much are trying to be
like an american company
and i think if they were a national
security threat i think that'd be the
end of their business
i think they'd be done if that were real
and they know it and the chinese
government
knows it and so i i i think i i
love watching them succeed and um but
frankly
you know over over time someone else is
going to come out from
some other probably america but some
other country and probably beat them at
their own game
at some point yeah kurt and i have
talked a lot about how the most
frustrating part about
all this spending so much time and
effort learning about this company and
writing about this company is that we
still don't really have the answer
to the national security question you
know we know that by dance and tick tock
say they don't give us
they don't give any data to the chinese
government that they host their data in
china
i mean in the u.s and in singapore um
but
you know there still remains to be the
case that china does have a
national security law that requires any
company to give them
over data and so it's really hard to
prove a negative you know what if
it's hard to prove that tick tock won't
do something in the future
or in the future um so i think it's it's
been a really tricky thing
um i i was curious um what it was like
um for you guys to participate in in the
podcast
and um kind of think think back
through you know kind of take a stroll
down down memory lane um
marjay uh maybe you can reflect a little
bit about what the process
was for was like for you yeah it was it
was definitely a
unique experience kind of uh reflecting
back on my time there that was
uh you know my first uh introduction
into the startup world
i came from google youtube
and left uh musically recruited me away
to um to uh start the la office
for musically and um it was a
an amazing you know experience to have
um you know so many unique
responsibilities and
and being part of um the early stages of
a company and it's um
it definitely had its ups and downs
um for sure being in a startup and um
and navigating personalities and and
different cultures as well
um and yeah i i enjoyed
having the opportunity to to think back
on
on those um those unique times uh so
so thanks for for sure it's really great
did you think back then
um what musically would turn into tick
tock and what tic toc would be now
i think i i think i i definitely saw the
vision for sure um unless i don't think
i would have uh
left google to to go there um i think
that um you know
i'm always excited to see what um
kids are are looking at in the
in the next array of of everything um
and i saw early on
when i was even interviewing there and
and learning more about the
the company um even in you know december
2015
um that there was something special that
they were creating and
uh speaking with um parents that
had kids that were you know engaging on
musically and
them telling us their stories about oh
you've you've helped my
my son or daughter become more confident
because they're
using musically to engage and
it's a unique experience for them and
it's helping them open up and be more
outgoing and all those things and um
and so it's it's definitely a i
definitely saw the vision and and
not surprised where it's at today
oh sorry go ahead no i was finished
i was going to say um john
i know the whole podcast hasn't come out
and you've only listened to a few
of the episodes um but curious to hear
what you think about reflecting on
on your time and you know taking part in
the podcast
yeah well it's been it's been great i
the whole thing i've loved to i love
talking about this
and um and and going through the history
of it all
has been wonderful the i i love this
stuff i've been doing this a long time
building businesses and tech and and
hoping you catch something and
scale something and and and ultimately
chan you're changing things
um you know flipagram and musically
and tick-tock is changing the way it
kind of the way we communicate and um
and i think the net is that the world's
becoming a better place there's side
effects there's some side effects
we've seen in recent years not just but
all over
social media we see these sort of
challenges but the net i think is that
um we're advancing culturally advancing
it's like a
a species so i love to be a part of it
and thinking back on it all
in all the trials and tribulations and
um was just one it was great that the
you know negotiating with the music
industry that was one of the most
challenging deals i'd ever done in my
life because
well we were we were you know using the
music illegally and so it was it's
harder it started out as you guys are
pirates
and we're going to sue you to you know
kingdom yeah
and and from that to like oh wow we're
i'm going to lose my house and
everything and
to um to where we are now and and just
the crazy
adventures and you know all that
happened throughout that it's been
really neat
yeah probably no other industry has gone
such a 180
on tick tock like to your point about
stealing the music and now
think of how much money they're making
off of this industry
well that was the case we made was that
this is gonna be
the next instagram this is gonna make
you tons of money
and you know
back then i if you had told me back then
how this played out i would have been
like oh really it's actually gonna
happen because
you know we totally believed it um
you know no one knows what's really
going on with this stuff and you're
we're all feeling our way through it
and um and it's amazing to think back
those early days when
you know we kind of consider ourselves a
glorified slideshow maker
um turning into you know something
world changing and kurt uh
what was it like to be reporting on this
podcast while everything was changing
week by week
there was kind of um you know i like to
listen i like to go back and listen to
some of these interviews we've done
because
um when you talk to someone you capture
this moment of time
that was just so different depending on
what what month you spoke to someone had
a different outlook for tick-tock
totally and you know there were there
was an added challenge of getting people
to
agree to talk right because it was like
right in the middle of
a geopolitical battle and so everyone
was like well i don't really want to go
on the record to like talk about
you know tick tock when the president of
the united states is
is trying to ban the app from the face
of the earth and so
it added an extra wrinkle but i think
the thing that's cool about podcasts
and just you know i always i always feel
this way when i write a story is like i
listen to the audio of the interview
and it's like i wish i could grab the
quotes as actual audio quotes because
the
the voice and the tone and the pauses
and and whatever it may be those tell
almost as much
about what that person's saying as the
words that they say
and so in print you miss that right and
um i think with a podcast you just have
so much more
opportunity to sit down for an hour
and be comfortable and really dig in on
a topic
and so it just creates like a totally
different reporting experience and
um you know obviously shelley you and
sean did
95 of the work on this thing but it was
fun to be
associated and kind of get the
experience of what it's like to
to put together something like this
because it is a very different reporting
experience
than than doing print yeah that was
definitely
one of my biggest lessons learned that
sean
told me from day one the producer
extraordinaire that she is
is that you know you have to listen
people's tone of voice
the way they say something is just so
different
than in the written word um john
marjay i was curious um you know
johnny mang the ceo of bite dance and
alex jew
um of musically and now still working at
bite dance
are still not really well known to to a
lot of people
what would you say or like maybe one or
two things that
um you know people should know about
them
go ahead marchand well first um i would
definitely say alex
uh certainly
is and was and is a visionary um when it
comes to
um you know his initial uh
vision of what musically could be and
become um
and it's really it was a really great
opportunity to work
alongside him and um and see and and
work
um next to such genius and um i think
he uh i think there's sometimes
the um i think a lot of times there was
uh he was kind of mystical right so i
think
um he he didn't necessarily always want
to be in the spotlight per se in the
first place and so i think
um it's kind of based on his personality
but uh he definitely
um had a lot of passion for what he was
doing and
put a lot of time into it and obviously
and um
you know this is what we see today from
a lot of the work
that he did in um you know early stages
being able to be on the ground floor and
and growing the app to
you know when i was there from 60
million to
you know over 300 million um was a
really
an amazing experience and um looking
forward to
to in the future and my my future goals
so it was really great
and um yeah thank you for for having me
and john what do you think is you know
something that isn't really as well
known
about um jung yaming as as maybe should
be
yeah i mean i didn't spend a ton of time
with him i'd had a few
a few times with him in beijing and in
la
um you know a very kind and humble man
which is not typical of people in that
role at least in my experience
he he's very patient
about things in tech things move
real fast and you're iterating fast
competition's moving fast and there's
this sort of urgency
that i i i've always seen
had in the tech world but it doesn't
seem to be going that way with him
he he's like playing some long game
somehow
um so there's like a patience and a long
view
um and you know
i think he really does look at american
tech
as a model for the company he's building
maybe not the leaders
of those companies but the way they're
built the way they
operate that seems to be like his
he seems to look at that as
for how he's building his company and
and you know you just walk around the
office in beijing and there's the quotes
from us businessmen and the
videos of of american tech leaders
the way the the the free lunch like you
know google has and
you know so i think he's trying to
take some elements of what's going on
here but
he definitely has his own uh persona
that i like i i you know i thought it
was very he's very gracious
and kind and i appreciate that more than
the
high and mighty super charismatic type
thank you that that's so fascinating um
okay that is it for the founding podcast
live q
a thank you all so much for joining us
today you heard from marjay roberts
ex-musical employee and founder of new
notions
john bolton ex-bike dance employee and
founder of super hi-fi
kurt wagner social media reporter for
bloomberg
and shelly banjo host of the founding
podcast
and myself sean one um keep downloading
and listening to
the foundering podcast new episodes drop
every thursday
it's available for free on spotify apple
or wherever you get your podcasts
see you next time thank you thanks for
having me
see ya bye